What's up guys.
All right. So, um, today what we're going to do,
we are going to interview a quant. Now, what does a Quan,
a quant is usually called a quantitative researcher or a quantitative analyst.
What they do is they work for hedge funds.
I think what they do is they use mathematical models, statistics, you know,
all of these rigorous tools to try to predict a market or try to, you know,
think about good investment strategies for hedge fund to make tons and tons of
money.
And why do I want to interview a quant is because it is the highest paying
job. Like if you come out of college and you go straight to a quant,
you can get up to like starting salary, like $200,000. And also that's not even,
what's most appealing about it. It's the bonuses. Now the bonuses,
they can go up to like half a mil. You know,
it's not a surprise that after you worked different four years,
you might get the total compensation of a million dollars a year.
So we are going to interview quantity.
And also this is a little bit special because this quantity is my
brother. So yeah. Hope you enjoy the interview.
Welcome to the Jomo show.
It's not called Jones show anymore because now I'm doing flogs.
But I know it hasn't been a while since I've done the interview and today we
have a special guest David ma.
So he is a special person,
highly requested because he used to work as a quant at two Sigma.
Is that correct? That's correct. That is cool.
So a little intro questions that I usually ask all my viewers.
So Mac or PC Mac, easy iPhone or Android?
iPhone. Wow. You're a fan boy. Yep.
Favorite language Spanish.
Yeah, it sounds very nice. Favorite programming. Oh, I see.
I see. What do you think?
Because people always make that mistake. I'm like, Oh my God.
Which, um, you know, I don't really care.
I use Java now. Okay.
Well, yeah, we use Java. Wow. Like on your startup. Yeah.
We'll talk about this later. Uh, what about.
Favorite editor? Uh, Microsoft word. Um,
also ambiguous because the ideas aren't really nice now these
days. Right. Um, but I used to use them otherwise. Yeah. Yeah.
I mean, honestly I use them because of you. Yeah.
Because it gives you me and you gotta, you got to suck it up. Yeah.
Pretty much learn all these commands and stuff. But, um, yeah.
I remember you started [inaudible].
Because you weren't at Facebook, right? No, no, no, no. Uh,
VIM was first year university. Like I SSH,
like I had to use something, um,
and VIM was one of the choices and like people said it was good,
but then I really got good at Facebook because like,
that was a pretty much one of the only choices. Oh.
Wait, I got one more and user submitted tabs or spaces.
Obviously spaces.
Well, you press space or you mean like you tab,
but then they become space space. Yeah. That's a big,
big differentiator. Yeah. All right. Cool.
So I heard you are a quantitative researcher, uh, is correct. Yeah.
So wait, where'd you work again? Uh, two Sigma. Oh, interesting.
I didn't know that. Well, you're a bad brother. Yeah. All right, cool. So, okay.
What is two Sigma?
Uh, two Sigma is a quantitative hedge fund. Um,
they use mathematics statistics, computer science to, uh,
make money on this stock markets on various financial. Right.
Okay, cool. Cool. And then as a quant, what do you do?
Uh, there's different types of quants? Uh, the stuff that I did was to find,
to predict, uh, the movements of stock prices and, uh,
through, you know, statistics. Yes.
I see. So basically you do a lot of like forecasting forecasting, again.
That's a good word. Okay, cool.
So you're trying to predict movements and then you're going to bet on that and
stuff like that. And then you probably have like a lot of different,
what else do you have to do with, you have to have, like, I heard a lot of them,
the term, what is it alpha, what does that mean?
Offer is just a term to signify that you've, um, uh,
you're able to predict the market better than, uh,
the average person on the market.
Oh, got it. Got it. Okay. So hired alpha. Yeah.
It was about a higher alpha the bedroom cab. Okay. It seems pretty simple. Um,
just a quick question. How much stats,
background or math background do you need to be successful as a Quan cause is it
like, do you have to be genius? You know, did you do competitions?
Definitely not. Uh, it's good to have a solid understanding,
like a basic understanding of statistics to not make the worst mistakes. Got it.
Um, like personally I took third year stats,
third and fourth year stats at Waterloo, which is not, you know,
it's not graduate level or anything like that, but basically the,
the most important things I think is, uh, to have creativity and to,
uh, think critically about your data and like about the process where
that data was generated. I think that's more,
much more important than like the actual statistics. Right.
So when you mean creativity, what do you mean?
The reason why I ask is because I would think I need creativity as a data
scientist,
but also because I think I'm a lot less technical than you in terms of like
stats knowledge. Because a lot of the times I'm just like, all right,
let's just average these things up. And then let's just take that variance.
Even if there's, they're like, Whoa, like the whole correlated, right.
Maybe for you. Um, some, I mean, just talking about those kinds of, uh, stats,
like, Oh, that's actually kind of enough,
as long as you're aware of where your biases are, right.
Your effects are so much larger than whatever bias. Like, it doesn't matter,
like that's a good case,
but when you're trying to find like tiny differences and sure. It will matter,
but hopefully that's not the case because you want to find a lot of alpha.
Right. And that's where the creativity comes in.
You want to find things that other people have not thought of. Maybe like, Oh,
let's use satellite imagery to look at, um,
how full Wells are in order to predict, uh,
some commodity prices and stuff like that. That was creative. Yeah. Um,
at some point it became not creative because I want to do a lot of it. Yeah.
Got it.
So are you saying that like strategies, like for hedge funds,
if you're the only one doing it, you might be profitable,
but if everyone starts doing it.
That's great. It becomes that's profitable. That's called crowdedness.
Interesting.
So I heard, you know,
especially from friends at Citadel that they work super long hours, you know,
it's hard. And then a lot of the times when I asked software engineers,
if they would like to switch to finance, because they know that finance,
they pay a lot, you know, but then they always come with the excuse saying,
yeah, but I don't want that like crazy work hours. So is it true? Like,
do you work long hours? Okay.
It depends on the like personally at two Sigma.
It was not that long.
I think I average 10 hours, 10 hours a day. Okay. Um,
and it's not like it's not 10 hours of like intense.
You have to be always on like, first of all, that was research.
That's what I did. Uh, software engineering is probably, um,
even less hours, uh, at two Sigma,
the culture at two Sigma was like someone of a, of a balanced culture, uh,
between life and work. Uh,
so they wanted people that would come in and not, uh,
you know, uh, have a good, have a good life,
not leave a long leave too soon. Yeah. That makes sense.
It's it might be true in other companies. Um,
that two Sigma was pretty balanced. Yeah.
Do you have any friends who came from Silicon Valley then worked at finance or
worked at finance then Silicon Valley. And how do you know how they compare?
Like.
I think it was pretty similar. Pretty similar. Yeah.
Of course the things that you're working on was pretty different. Um,
but like to see my, try to make, uh, you know,
Silicon Valley style culture. Yeah.
So you think it's the same for like Citadel and like other finance companies?
It's hard to know. I mean, I've never been there. Uh,
they are competitors. They work. Yeah.
Nice. Nice. Okay. So let's talk about your background.
So how did you get into Quan? Like first?
How did you discover it and what do you think like a background should be to be,
you know, to get an interview?
Right. At least the first time that I heard about like quants,
um, was in my CJ, had it, I had this professor,
uh, he was like, it was 2007, right. Uh, financial crash and like,
like housing crisis and stuff like that. He was like blaming, Oh,
it's the clients like, this is the past stuff.
They use their mathematical models to, to create the financial disaster.
I was talking to my friend. I was like, Oh yeah, that's my guy.
That's why I want to be, you know, and he actually became one.
I didn't even know what it, what it was.
Cause like at that time I wanted to be an actuarial, uh, major.
Cause I was like, Oh, I like math. Let's, let's see what I can do with math.
And that's all I knew. Um, but like through the years,
uh, at, uh, at Waterloo, um, you know, I learned how to code,
I learned about predictive statistics. And then at some point I near the end,
I was like, well, all these things together. Um,
well it was a good fit for, for it to be a yeah.
Research quantity.
So what was your major in, uh, university of Waterloo?
Mathematics and mathematics at Waterloo is very ambiguous. Yeah. Uh,
you can like take whatever you want.
Yeah. So you took stats. Where were you like a math genius? Like,
did you do contests?
I mean, I did contest when I was, uh,
in high school ranked second in Quebec. Uh,
I didn't know about other. You didn't know that? Oh yeah.
I guess only there's only one, uh, competition that ranked second.
That was like my peak. Uh, but otherwise, no,
I wouldn't consider myself genius in any way.
It was more combination of multiple things that led to God. Yeah.
It was a computer science stats, uh, and some interest in finance.
So if you had to tell a high schooler, like my boy, Matt show behind the camera,
or like an early college student. Yeah. They want to be a quantity.
We really want to be a Quan, but like,
don't even tell me if it's actually my passion or not, but just,
I just want to be quiet. Okay. What do you do right now?
Computer science, uh, stats do some Kaggle competitions.
I think that's good.
That is one thing that I discovered pretty early on and I ranked like some,
somewhere to the top 10 for a competition.
Humble bragging interview for you. Stop saying that you're still talking. Okay.
But.
That was at the time when it was easy.
Okay, cool. Cool. Nice.
'Cause now like, there's like so many PhDs, like it's super competitive.
K on Kaggle. It's overcrowded. Yes, that's right.
All right. So what about like, um, like interviewing at these companies? How,
how hard is it or like what kind of questions do you ask?
I would say it's hard because not because
maybe not because of the questions they asked,
but because so many people want to apply like
these days. I wonder if, if I apply now, whether I would get in,
it's kind of a, what kind of questions do they ask technical questions?
Obviously you have to know your computer science.
You have to know your statistics.
I spent a whole day just going through all these questions that people
compiled online. Okay. Where do you find these questions? Um,
like behind the.
Cracking, the coding interview.
Yeah. Cracking the code, um, uh, glass door.
There's like some quant one that people have compiled like more statistics and
like more, uh, probably questions brainteasers um,
like just go through all of them. It's like, just to maximize your chances,
these honestly, I don't think it's like a really good, um, you don't,
it's not like you use this on the job, uh, especially the brain teasers,
but it kind of filters out the people who are like, Oh, I'm going to Yolo this.
Right, right, right. Okay. So basically hardworking people. Yeah. It's,
it's it filters with some training. Yeah.
Inclusion. From what I understand, uh, quants, you know, they,
they they're basically like data scientists.
I feel like they're a little bit more rigorous, you know,
they use mathematical models to try to predict markets so that they can make
money for the hedge fund was a good summary. Cool. All right.
So let's talk about a little bit of, uh, you know, you as a person, you know,
cause, um,
we want to know like how does one habit interesting to Quan?
So thinking about when you were a kid,
do you think you had like behaviors where it kind of indicated that you're more
of a technical person, a more mathematical person? You know,
like for me.
I was, yeah. So there you can go first.
Well, for me, I think it was just like playing games that are like RTS that,
you know, how you had to manage money or stuff like that.
Or also like building stuff in kingdom hearts.
I remember know that that would be a very engineering dream.
Yeah. That was very impressive. I really enjoyed reading, uh,
detective stories.
Oh yeah. I don't know how that relates to Quan.
Because you have to investigate data. Right.
I find now like as a data scientists, it's, it's kind of like a,
you're kind of like a detective, but you're your subject is data.
You have things that you want to investigate and you have to like find ways of
like answering that question through evidence. Right. Um.
I like the, I really like that analogy. Cause it feels like in the end,
the data is just data and then all the statistic, goal knowledge,
even if you're really technical, it doesn't make you a better data scientist.
Right. What's important. Right.
Is the questions you asked and how you get to those answers.
And also like being able to take synthesize all the evidence that you've,
that you've, uh, you've found and into like one coherent story.
Right. That's like a very detective thing to do. Right.
Cause like if there one,
like if there's like one piece of evidence that doesn't fit with the story it's
something's wrong. Right.
Okay. Cool. So what about, let's talk about now,
what do you do outside of work aside from, you know, when you actually work,
what are your hobbies? Um.
I do photography a bit these days. It's like your Instagram.
I mean, it's not that good. [inaudible].
I haven't, I haven't done much in a, in a while. Um.
Wait, your hand was actually at the VidMob. Yeah. Wow.
So lucky also have david.ma.
Yeah. You can check out his website. It's pretty good.
Yeah. It's pretty. Yeah. I needed some sort of designer contact me, DM me.
Wow. It's literally just a yeah. And it's and it's super outdated.
It says I'm a quantitative. Oh yeah. It's not true anymore.
Right? True. Yeah. So you're not a quad anymore. So what do you do now?
Uh, I work at a startup. Um, we're still very small.
We are building a real estate agent's assistance and we help,
uh, real estate agents, uh, schedule things with prospects,
manage their schedules, collect data about their performances, uh, so that,
you know,
just this stuff can be automated so that they can focus on the stuff they do
best, which is selling to, uh, people who come in.
Cool. Cool. You guys doing well.
Pretty well. I think pretty well. Nice.
All my discord channel.
I also asked them to ask you guys you questions or us questions.
How to get your little brother eight girlfriend.
It's hopeless. It's hopeless. It's hopeless.
Yeah. Why do you think it's hopeless? What's what's wrong with me?
I have theories, but why do you think?
Well, I was actually kidding. He's actually tons of girls.
He just doesn't tell you guys. That's not true. It's not part of my brand.
Next question. What was Jomo? Like when he was younger?
Yes. Confidence. Oh really? Yes. That's true. Yeah. That's true.
I think that summarizes the biggest, the biggest difference. Yeah.
All right. Next question. Favorite video games or yeah.
Um, probably smash. Oh really? Yeah. Yeah. That makes sense. I mean,
I hate that. You're better than me. I'm still good, but like it's a really,
it's a really good smash Millie. Yeah.
You never have to learn the advanced technique still. Yeah. That's true.
That's where you're not blocked. Yeah. I was like,
I'm like trying to weave that or like
who.
Is smarter Joel or Dave.
Then I'm going to give a serious answer for this one. Really serious answer.
When I was a kid, I thought I was smarter. No, I think you,
I think you're so much smarter because as a kid,
I like in the earliest stages, I thought like,
Oh yeah,
like IQ tests and like math and like being clever at those kinds of things
was meant that you were smarter. And I think I'm better than that.
That kind of stuff
I realized like after some university and like, especially after,
after that, that there was so many ways of being smart.
And I kind of find that in general,
like I find you learn things faster than me.
And I think now I think you're smarter than me.
Thank you. What kind of music are you going to put on?
I don't know. I'll have to think about it. You're smarter than me.
[Inaudible].
But yeah. But yeah, definitely like, thank you. First of all,
it's very nice for you to say, but no.
But it was not, uh, it was not the charity.
No, thank you. Thank you. Yeah. Um, yeah, but I do want to say like, yeah,
definitely like quantitative wise and stuff like that.
You were always like smarter.
Sometimes it did feel like I was like living under your shadow in some ways.
Right. I guess it's cute like that. Yeah.
But, uh, but yeah, like, um, I'm glad,
like hopefully someday I feel like, cause you,
in some ways paved the way for me in terms of like my education,
what I did and stuff like that. I just hope that one day I can like give back,
you know, I think.
You are already doing it at scale kind of thing. Yeah. Thank you. Cool.
You don't have a smaller, a younger brother, but right, right, right. Yeah.
You're doing what you can. I think in the end, like whenever we're successful,
you should just lead the way for some other people.
[Inaudible].
No, I'm just, I'm just trying to make money on my YouTube channel. All right.
So thank you for watching. If you liked this video,
don't forget to like and subscribe.
And if you want to see some of my brother's photography, it's David ma.
[Inaudible].